Deck the Halls if you want some donuts
and then you can have some beer with it
deck the Hops hauls with hops and barley
I messed up the song anyway the Nevada
craft Brewers Association is presenting
Brew Festivus it's a brew Festivus for
the rest of us it's a week from Saturday
at downtown Summerlin all benefits a
great cause and windy Forest is here to
tell us more about that she's the
president of ncba and the owner of
crafthouse thanks for being here today
yeah thanks for having us this is the
first year of this event but this will
become a Christmas tradition yeah
yeah we need the poll and everything
right yeah so we want people to cover
your grievances we're making a donation
to The Human Fund how great
so uh Pearl seeds will be split between
Three Square Food Bank which does
wonderful work in our community and also
Nevada craft Birds Association so we can
advance the state for craft beer yeah
you have more than 30 members of The
Craft Brewers Association people like
you who are passionate about this art
and they're coming together and people
can sample different beers yeah so
they'll be all Nevada made beers and
they'll be over 50 different beers most
of them holiday inspired for people to
try so how do people get tickets and get
involved so you can get tickets if you
go to Eventbrite and search Brew
Festivus or you can go to our website at
nevadabear.com and this has been a
passion for you for a long time craft
house you started back eight years ago
something like that right yeah but even
before then this is something that
sparked you yeah it's it's nice because
craft beer really brings people together
and especially during the holidays
that's what we all kind of yearn for so
bring bringing people together and
celebrating and enjoying a wonderful
nevada-made product is we think you have
some examples up here what are some of
these so this one is crayon Apple clink
clink so it is a sour with cranberry and
apple okay and um holiday spices that's
from Abel Baker this is from big dogs
it's a peppermint bark bark so that's a
stout with peppermint flavors peppermint
beer yes okay the one in the middle
that's from bad beat that's called dress
to the nines and that one has a fun
Rim packet so you Rim your glass before
you drink it and then we also have
huddle Brewing they're downtown and they
have their famous toasted pecan ale okay
again where can people get tickets or
get involved yep so you can go to
Eventbrite and search uh Brew Festivus
or you can go to nvbeer.com all right
and tell people where to find craft
house a crafthouse is in Henderson we're
at the booze District but we also have a
Tasting Room in the arts district
downtown as well all right Wendy thanks
so much for being here today good luck
with your event a week from